welcome back can smoking marijuana make
you blind pop star Ed Sheeran claims
that Snoop Dogg got him so high on weed
one time that it happened to him
I don't really smoke at all and I was in
I was in the dressing room and there
just you know blunt for blunt for blunt
for blunt and I'm like I guess at some
point during the night I have to just to
be like let's move so I have a bit and
I'm like I don't feel too bad this is
good and then I have a bit more then I
have a bit more then I have a bit
oh my God I just remember looking at him
being like I can't see right now
well you like drugs the most of anyone
at the table maybe yeah yes yeah well I
mean it's no surprise that snoop's weed
is powerful he's been smoking all of his
life it's the equivalent of trying to
hit a Nolan Ryan fastball because you
once played in Little League so was it
but was it because it was Smokey or
because he was too high don't pretend
I'm just asking journalistic questions
all right about the situation I was
always told something else if you did it
too much it would make yeah yes did you
go to Catholic schools too no let me
tell you okay I understand that Snoop
has an official roller who says she's
Twisted 450 000 blunts since she started
working for him in 2016. he apparently
smokes 80 blunts a day a day no I mean
why isn't it possible
I don't know don't ask yourself how many
blunts an hour is that yeah I don't know
I don't know that's why we're not on
Wall Street
80 blunts a day that's like 24 hours if
you're smoking Around the Clock 18 hours
18 hours yeah and why don't we ask Tyrus
wasn't he is by the guard yes he would
know he would know he would know Tyrus
hold on we'll talk to Tyrus hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else